I'm Sandy Irani and I'm the associate
director of the Simons Institute many of
you in the room are already familiar
with the Simons Institute but others who
might be listening in
um we are the leading uh venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science and the Simons
Institute was founded in 2012 with a
very generous Grant from the Simons
foundation and we bring together
researchers from all over the world
um to and our programs focus on studying
science engineering in the world through
an algorithmic lens and we bring in
computer scientists and people from all
kinds of related fields to study a great
variety of topics
um
a little bit about today's event we are
hybrid today so if you're in the room
you can just raise your hand and ask a
question
um and I will be monitoring online to
see if we have anyone uh attending
remotely who'd like to ask a question
um so this particular lecture series The
Richard M carp distinguished lecture
series
um was founded to celebrate the many
contributions of uh the Simon's
foundations
um uh founding director
uh Richard M karp and his many
contributions in establishing the field
of theoretical computer science and
formulating its Central problems
um we're very grateful to the many
people who have contributed to make this
particular lecture series possible and
uh the lecture series focuses and uh uh
hosts distinguished speakers such as the
one we have today
um and uh covers topics for a broad
scientific audience today it's
especially nice to have Suchi Chala
joining us today she's from UT Austin
um where she holds an endowed
professorship and is also an Amazon
scholar her work is on algorithm design
but specifically at the intersection of
computation and economics
um
so before coming to UC Austin's shoot
you spent 15 years at the University of
Wisconsin in Madison and she's won
numerous awards for her research and
teaching a Sloan Fellowship Chancellor's
award for Innovative teaching and it's
really a pleasure to have her joining us
today the top of her talk is Pandora's
Box learning to leverage costly
information so please join me in
welcoming shuchi
[Applause]
introduction Sandy this is uh this talk
is based on a couple of recent works
with these co-authors and the lead
student author on the verxes right here
evangelia and so if you have any
technical questions you know who to ask
um okay so let me start by uh saying a
few words about the data-driven decision
processes program that I'm participating
in uh this semester and how today's talk
fits into uh the framework of this
program uh this program is about uh
sequential or online uh decision
processes and and techniques for that uh
uh and we're uh you know discussing
techniques to solve these kinds of
online uh or sequential uh
decision-making processes and one of the
key aspects of uh these sorts of
problems is this lack of information
about what input is to arrive in the
future we need to make decisions before
we know this entire input but on the
other hand uh oftentimes we are also in
this uh setting where we can actually
gather a lot of data about uh this input
so for example we might have examples of
fast input that we see in for the same
problem or a model of the input
generating process predictions or hints
about what's to come in the future and
so on and one of the things we are
discussing in this program is how to
effectively use this data in our in and
incorporate it into decision making
so what about today's talk today our
Focus will be on settings where this
information comes at a cost so we don't
get it for free and the question is uh
you know when should we decide to buy
this information in such a way that it
actually helps improve uh the uh
optimization we're carrying out okay so
that's the key question what should we
what pieces of information should we
purchase in what order for it to be the
most effective from the point of view of
optimization and the sort of problem
comes up in many many different contexts
I have a few examples here from like uh
real life examples that we might face as
individuals in fact but these kinds of
problems arise uh in in you know a
variety of different settings so you can
imagine for instance a student that's
looking to select a college and visits
different campuses to figure out how
much they uh you know like the place and
every such visit uh you know costs a bit
in terms of both time and effort and
money and so you know the question is
where should they go and maybe they
don't want to visit all of the different
places uh on their list right
uh likewise imagine that you are looking
to buy a piece of furniture and uh you
know you visit uh various different
stores to find the best deal you know
what is the order in which you should go
to these stores when should you decide
you've seen enough and you you just want
to buy the best you've seen so far
likewise when you're trying to purchase
a house you know should you get it
inspected it comes at a cost uh you know
which houses should you look at first
Etc or if you're trying to recruit a
specialist uh you might invest time or
effort or money into you know uh trying
them out or interviewing them uh before
you make a selection
and in all of these different contexts
uh so there's a a cost for uh you know
getting the next piece of information
and it has some effect on how well uh at
the end of the day you'll be able to run
your optimization and we're going to
talk about a very nice and simple model
that was uh proposed by Martin Weitzman
back in 1979 that captures precisely
this kind of trade-off between the cost
of information and the benefit it
provides in the optimization problem
so in this problem that Weitzman called
Pandora's problem uh Pandora has a bunch
of different boxes that contain unknown
costs in them uh so his original problem
was uh in the the context of uh rewards
contained inside boxes we'll talk about
costs today
so every box contains a cost and our
underlying optimization problem is very
simple we just want to find the box with
the smallest cost
we at the end of the process we'll be
choosing one box out of these and and
the cost of this box is is the objective
you're trying to minimize and at the
beginning all we know is that these
costs are drawn According to some
distributions and we know these
distributions
but furthermore before we make our
selection we can open any of these boxes
to reveal the precise cost contained
inside them and this opening comes at uh
at a certain further cost that I'll call
a probing penalty and so for example you
know the algorithm might decide to open
box one pay T1 for opening this and
realizes this cost C1 that's drawn from
this distribution
and then at this point the algorithm
might decide to open box three to get
more information
and pays uh the penalty of T3 realizes
the cost C3 and the process could
continue in this fashion until at some
point the algorithm decides that it's
seen enough and then it makes a choice
so perhaps it picks this cost uh this
box three
and so the total loss of the algorithm
is going to be the cost of this chosen
box that's C3 here plus the total
penalty the algorithm paid for opening
whichever boxes it opened
and this is the total quantity we want
to minimize
okay
so I'll point out here that uh you know
there are lots of contexts in which we
place a cost of on information and
oftentimes the way we formalize it into
the an optimization setting is to you
know uh place a budget on how much we
can spend on gathering this information
so this is quite a different model in
that it sets up this direct trade-off
between how much you pay for information
and uh and how it affects your
optimization by bringing this cost
straight into the objective okay and
that's what makes uh this uh Pandora's
Box model a little bit different from
other kind of budgeted settings that you
might be familiar with
so do we have to probe the Box we select
very good question so for this talk I
will assume you have to probe the Box uh
that we select uh but I'll talk very
briefly about the non-obligatory setting
as well
and we always have
fun
you must select at least one box yes so
we're in this past minimization setting
we must select at least one box
otherwise you know we could have just uh
yeah so this is a requirement is the
recall or can you go back to a box that
you are yes so you can go back to a box
you've seen before so when you stop you
could look at all of the boxes you've
seen before and you could pick the best
of them the cheapest with them yeah
thank you all great questions and please
feel free to continue to ask questions
okay so what is a solution to this
problem look like so there are two
things an algorithm needs to do it needs
to figure out which box to probe next
and when it should stop and make a
selection and once it decides to stop it
just chooses the cheapest box it's seen
so far
and in general both of these uh
decisions can depend on all of the
information the algorithm has uh seen so
far so in general uh a strategy for this
problem looks like a decision tree where
you know you make some probes and then
depending on the outcomes of these
probes you decide what to do next
and so at this point uh you know the
national next question is well how large
can this tree be you know this looks
kind of complicated
and you know if it if it's large can we
represent it succinctly somehow and is
it efficiently computable those are the
next questions of course we ask as
algorithm designers and the upshot and
I'll talk about these uh in some more
detail of course but the upshot is that
the tree can indeed be exponential in
size the optimal tree uh we don't know I
don't know if any uh results about
whether it's succinctly representable
but in terms of computability the upshot
is that it's going to be hard to compute
and I'll say more I'll go into more
details in a little bit
but so at this point our goal then will
be to ask well when can we approximate
it or what can we approximate or what
can we optimize
so this is what happens in general uh
but let's go back to weitzman's work
from 79 what did uh Weitzman show well
he came up with a very very nice and
elegant algorithm for solving Pandora's
box under certain settings and I'll
describe this algorithm to you through a
picture here uh it won't be directly
relevant to uh what I have to say later
but it's it's kind of a very nice
algorithm to know about
so what this does is it computes uh
indices for each of the boxes uh and
these are just like uh pretend costs for
the boxes and I use I'm using GI to
denote these indices because these are
the same as uh kittens indices uh if uh
some of you know what get in synthesis
are turns out that Weitzman
independently came up with the same
solution as kittens did to this sort of
a problem
uh okay so what this does is uh
essentially these indices are a way of
taking the probing penalties and
amortizing them in a certain way so that
they can be absorbed into the costs of
the boxes and now we can just forget
about all the probing penalties and just
ask to uh uh you know find the the box
with the cheapest cost with these
pretend costs and so what is the
algorithm going to do well uh once we
compute these indices uh we're gonna
open the cheapest one these are now our
pretend costs
okay and so we open this and we observe
the true cost in this box and maybe it
turns out to be this C1
and at this point we still have some
boxes that have indices or pretend costs
that are smaller than the one we
observed and so we continue opening them
we open uh the second box and then we
open the third box and at some point we
find a box where the true cost in the
box is uh smaller than everything else
uh uh you know either other observed
costs or pretend costs of the boxes we
haven't opened yet and that's the one
the one we select okay
so the thing to notice is uh first these
indices are easy to compute they're only
functions of every individual box
and second you know there's no
adaptivity here in the probing order you
just compute these indices and we're
going to open boxes in this or
increasing order of their pretend costs
so a much nicer and simpler than a large
decision tree
that might appear in general
so uh Wiseman showed that in fact this
simple algorithm turns out to be optimal
under the assumption that these cost
distributions are independent
okay
and I told you of course a few minutes
ago that uh you know in general uh we're
not going to get this nice structure so
it also turns out that this theorem is
quite brittle and it breaks as soon as
we change some little facet of uh the uh
the setting okay so here are some uh
settings where uh this theorem fails to
hold uh non-obligatory inspection this
is uh what ola mentioned this is when
you can actually select boxes without
opening them so you don't have to open a
box to select it
um you know I can choose a college to go
to without visiting the campus
another setting where it breaks is when
costs are correlated this is uh you know
already in the theorem statement so for
instance I go to a public university and
decide that I don't like it very much
which indicates I probably don't like
other public universities so that gives
me some information about how uh what
kind of scenario or world I'm in and if
costs are correlated in this fashion
then again a white sense solution uh
breaks
approach breaks
another setting is if we are in some
sort of combinatorial context where uh
you know we
select multiple boxes or we're required
to select multiple boxes and we have
some combinatorial feasibility
constraint uh and uh work of sahil here
who's in the audience does a very nice
job of uh explaining where weitzman's
algorithm works and where it doesn't and
it turns out that in in many settings it
doesn't work another related context is
this problem called attribute selection
which is of a similar nature where
decisions over boxes are required to be
correlated in in some sense in in a
combinatorial sense and uh once again
this kind of approach fails to work
okay
so the question we want to ask in this
talk is uh you know in these uh more
general settings where we don't have a
nice structure on the solution uh of the
uh optim on the optimal strategy what
can we say about learning and
approximation and I'll focus in this
talk on uh the setting of correlated
costs but some of the observations we
make will also apply to other settings
okay so as I said our goal is to develop
an algorithm for finding a probing
strategy for this problem and here are
some keywords to keep in mind so we want
to be able to compute the strategy
efficiently uh we want uh some sort of
approximation guarantee but also we'll
talk about learning in this context and
we'll talk about how much we need to
know about the underlying cost
distribution in order to be able to do
this computation okay so that's the
sense in which learning will come in
here
okay and in the rest of the talk I'll
start by uh talking about some different
distributional models uh for correlated
costs and then we'll talk about some uh
algorithmic components that we need to
be able to solve in order to construct a
solution to Pandora's Box and we'll try
to understand those in isolation and
then we'll put things together to come
up with uh some results okay
any questions so far
okay so here are the two distributional
settings I'll talk about so again we
have uh costs inside these n different
boxes that we can open and reveal and at
the end of the day we want to select one
box and get its cost and in general
these costs are going to be distributed
According to some joint distribution and
when we have these joint distributions
this is over an n-dimensional space
these can be very complicated
distributions and so these these two
models are sort of uh very natural first
models that one might think of in this
sort of
high dimensional context the first one
is just a small support distribution so
uh something of this sort so here we
have three boxes and so cost vectors are
uh are three-dimensional vectors and you
know this is just a distribution with
some a small number of vectors in its
support and some distribution over those
okay so we could be given something
explicit like this and here the
complexity of the distribution will be
the number of different cost vectors
that can appear and in general uh you
know we should expect that our
algorithms runtimes or performance
guarantees to depend on this quantity
and then we'll also look at settings
where the distribution is completely
arbitrary so we don't have uh you know
an explicit model of it but we are given
M samples drawn from it and the samples
here are again going to be these cost
vectors so the M samples and
deliberately using the same M here
because the M samples the empirical
distribution will look something exactly
something like this
okay
and now let me talk about what goes into
constructing a strategy for Pandora's
Box and there are you know a few
different components uh we need to be
able to solve in order to design a
solution so uh one is that uh you know
when we open boxes they're giving us
multiple kinds of information they're
both telling us what kind of uh world we
are in okay so uh by uh state of the
world I really mean you know what is our
our cost Vector right so our
distribution is a distribution over cost
vectors and every time I open a
particular box so if I open this one and
I observe a cost of eight I know that
I'm in one of these three the different
potential states of the world and so one
of the things opening a box tells me is
uh information about the which state I'm
in another thing it does is helps me
find the low cost box so we want to be
able to gain information but we also
want to be able to
find the low cost box so there's some
tension between these two components
okay
and then of course we need to know when
to stop and so as we're gathering
information and finding smaller and
smaller costs when have we done enough
and now we can stop and make a choice
that's another component here and
finally we'll need to talk about how we
might learn uh in the setting where we
only have samples from the underlying
distribution
foreign
you can think of uh you know once you
draw the samples then you can think of
an empirical distribution over these
samples and then you can think about
what you can do over that empirical
distribution and then we can you know
grapple with the standard uh learning
question which is you know are these
samples enough to for we to be able to
generalize to the entire distribution
whatever results I get over the in terms
of distribution
[Music]
yeah yeah so that's a good question so
in this model we are uh this is uh
obligatory inspection uh that we're
talking about so uh once you have
identified which state of the world
you're in you still have to go and if
you haven't already uh seen a good
low-cost box for that state you might
need to go and pay the probing costs for
that but that's a decision algorithm can
make maybe it's already seen a good
enough box or maybe it knows that you
know it's worthwhile to pay for another
new box I think
okay so I'll talk about each of these
and I'll go and sort of uh uh a
different order than uh top to bottom uh
so let's talk about uh knowing when to
stop so the stopping rule here
and I'm starting with this because it
turns out that this problem is actually
very easy to solve approximately
okay so first of all the optimal
stopping rule can be very very complex
because the underlying distribution can
be very very complex right so there you
know you could have some strange kinds
of correlations between costs and your
stopping rule could depend on uh sort of
untangling those uh correlations
but it turns out that we can get a very
good approximation very easily and the
way we do this is a stopping rule that
I'll call myopic shopping and basically
what it does is uh you know once you
specify uh a decision tree for probing
once you know how to probe it's going to
just keep track of the total cost we've
paid for probing so it's going to keep
track of this total probing penalty and
as soon as this probing penalty exceeds
the best solution I've seen so far we're
going to stop and accept that best
solution okay and if you've seen uh sort
of the this key rental problem or the
render by problem before in online
algorithms this is exactly the solution
to that problem but let me also show you
a very quick analysis of why this is a
good idea
so we have some probing strategy some
order in which we're going to probe
boxes and the the thing to note here is
that if I plot the the penalty uh the
probing penalty that my algorithm is
paying uh this is a little blurry and my
apologies for that uh but you don't need
to see what's written here just the
colors so this this orange is uh
tracking the total probing penalty I'm
paying over time and the blue here is
tracking the cost of the best solution
I've seen so far so the least cost box
in our current context and this myopic
stopping what it says is we're going to
stop as soon as these uh the blue line
and the orange line cross each other and
the observation is that anywhere else
along this timeline either the blue
function is higher or the orange
function is higher okay and so our total
cost which is the sum of these and and
it's depicted by this green here is
going to be uh you know at least as
large as the uh the penalty or the cost
we have at this point but we're paying
no more than twice this point being the
sum of these
okay so basically this myopic stopping
is going to be a two approximation to
even the hindsight optimal stopping so
if I could just run this process forever
and observe what this hindsight optimal
stopping time is I'm still within a
factor of two of that and if I use a
little bit of Randomness we can even
improve this uh slightly and again this
is exactly like uh how Randomness helps
with this key rental problems
is like
two approximation of the like the way
you're selecting you're opening the box
it's not of the best
it's saying that if I fix a probing
strategy for this one for this
particular strategy yes my uh cost by
going to myopic stopping as opposed to
some other stopping rule is going to be
no more than twice
yes um so sometimes the best possible
probably it's a reward from each box so
can we still design a similar strategy
for this kind of version so that's a
really good question and there's a
reason I'm talking about costs here with
rewards you you get a mixed objective
where you you know you uh get the you're
trying to maximize the reward but you're
paying the probing penalty and with a
mixed objective uh you know things get
uh very messy in fact longer
approximations are possible so you can
show some very large gaps so yeah this
does not work out if you have the words
from point of view of optimality so
settings where for instance uh bison
solution works there is no difference
between cost and rewards but from the
point of view of approximation they can
be very different so we can talk more
offline
okay so the upshot here is that uh I
don't really need to worry about knowing
the best stopping time uh in fact we
don't need any further information about
the setting in order to be able to do
approximately optimally even against the
hindsight optimal stopping rule
so that's one problem we can move out of
the way
and next let's talk about the problem of
finding a low-cost box quickly okay and
here I want to talk about a special case
of the Pandora's Box problem which is uh
an optimization problem that's been
studied extensively uh in uh you know
motivated by other contexts as well and
this is called the Min sum set cover
problem
and this is essentially the special case
where all of the boxes are going to
contain costs that are 0 or Infinity
okay so I want you to think of this as a
setting where uh boxes come with uh you
know a note inside that says this is
acceptable or this is unacceptable
okay and all we want to do is we want to
find an acceptable box and as soon as we
can find an acceptable box we we end the
process
okay
so uh here's a really quick example of
this we have five scenarios these are
the rows here we have four boxes these
are the columns here and every box in
every scenario is going to be acceptable
or unacceptable and again we are going
to try out and open these boxes one at a
time and we're trying to minimize how
many boxes we need to open before we
find an acceptable one so for example if
we open this box first if it were the
case that we were in this scenario or
this scenario then uh you know we we can
stop this box is already acceptable and
we'll think of you know the scenarios as
being getting covered by these boxes by
this particular box and we end these
scenarios with a penalty of one total
penalty of one
but if you're not in these scenarios
then we need to go and open another box
and maybe we open this one and this one
covers uh the second row and the fourth
row both of it's acceptable for both of
those uh scenarios and those scenarios
now have a penalty of two okay because
we opened two boxes
and if we're in this first scenario we
still haven't found uh an acceptable box
yet and maybe we opened this one and
then again the process ends and now our
penalty is three
so the total penalty we paid is is uh a
weighted average of these weighted
according to the uh probabilities of the
scenarios
and uh so this is called the Min sum set
cover problem because uh you know we're
summing the penalties and kind of each
penalty is how quickly you covered a
scenario uh with uh these sets these are
our sets okay
okay
so so that's a problem and it's it's a
special case of Pandora's Box because uh
you know it has this nice special cost
structure
and this is again a problem that turns
out to be easy to solve so anything with
a constant approximation I'll term easy
in anything without uh you know will be
a hard problem so this is MP hard okay
let's uh interest state that uh you know
it's not completely easy uh it captures
uh maximum coverage style problems but
it turns out that a very simple greedy
algorithm as you might expect gives a
good enough approximation in this greedy
algorithm simply says well we'll just uh
you know pick the box that covers the
most scenarios and then at the next step
pick the one that covers the most
remaining scenarios and so on okay so
very natural kind of algorithm
okay
so there are multiple ways of of getting
this for approximation and it's also
known to be tight so you can't do better
than for uh in polynomial time uh and uh
I'll consider this to be basically a
solved and well understood problem
but it doesn't quite uh you know it's
it's strictly less General than
Pandora's Box in a sense because you
know it doesn't quite capture the you
know this informational structure where
when you open a box maybe it has a very
high cost inside it but it might still
be a good idea to open it if it gives us
good information about uh you know you
know what else what state of the world
we are in and uh this problem doesn't
quite capture that structure
okay so that brings us to this first
problem here which is how quickly can we
gather information about which World
we're in
and here I want to tell you about
another related problem which has been
extensively studied this is called the
optimal decision tree problem and it's
uh the following problem so here uh we
are not interested in finding a low-cost
box we're just interested in finding
what state of the world we're in okay
and this this problem has a lot of
different applications uh you know for
instance disease diagnosis okay so now
the boxes are like tests and they reveal
some information about uh the underlying
states of the world to us and we want to
figure out you know how many tests do we
need to run before we we get a firm
diagnosis okay so there's a long line of
literature on this in many many
applications and it captures this
particular aspect of Pandora's Box so
what's known about this problem
so this is uh known to be NP hard even
when these tests are binary the prior is
uniform so like the nicest version of
this problem is already NP hard and the
challenge really uh in for this problem
is that uh you know there's uh so you're
you're running these tests opening these
boxes and you're gathering information
about the world piecemeal uh but you
know it's it's difficult to uh sort of
quantify uh the uh the gain of
information in a manner that's uh
algorithmically that's amenable to
algorithmic techniques so Information
Gain can be a a very difficult quantity
to work with uh and so uh there's a long
line of work on this and uh there are
these two sort of uh primary techniques
that have
um uh that have been useful in uh
developing approximations here one is to
uh come up with some sort of nice proxy
function for Information Gain that lends
itself to uh good approximations and
another is to sort of uh greedily and
successively eliminate uh large uh
sets of scenarios and and do that in a
an iterative fashion so it turns out
that one can get a a log in M
approximation for this problem M recall
is a number of different states of the
world
so and and this also turns out to be
tight in general so uh with an arbitrary
prior over the states of the world uh
there's an Omega log M lower bound on
what you can do uh in polynomial time
uh okay so uh and then I'll just quickly
mention that there's a nice special case
where this prior is uniform and here
there's a big gap in what we know for
for that particular setting so nice open
question If you're looking for one
okay so the upshot is that we can solve
this sort of uh exploration or isolation
problem uh when there are few states of
the world so when m is small and we are
happy to tolerate this logarithmic in M
uh approximation uh you know at least we
can uh try to express our problem as an
optimal decision tree problem and get a
solution that way
okay so this is what we know so far we
know when to stop if we have a probing
Rule and we know how to approximately
solve the exploration problem uh when m
is small and we'll talk about learning
uh in a few minutes but uh let's already
you know talk about how we can
synthesize these pieces to uh get an
algorithm for Pandora's Box in the
setting where we had this explicitly
described uh distribution so now we have
these M states of the world we're given
this model explicitly
and essentially this boils down to
making connections between these
problems uh I talked about and so I said
that uh you know optimal decision tree
solves the the problem of learning
information about the world but it
doesn't have to deal with costs Min
Sunset cover uh you know actually it
does not capture the informational
aspect and so uh instead we uh consider
a version of minsa said minsum set cover
that incorporates feedback so you still
have zero infinite costs inside boxes
but these zeros and Infinities carry
along with them uh you know information
about what state of the world you're in
and with these definitions one can show
that Pandora's Box is essentially
equivalent to Min Sunset cover
and these reduce and turn into optimal
decision tree
and this reduction here
is essentially the observation that once
you can figure out the state of the
world uh you know you can exploit the
state of the world so I won't go into
details here but this this turns out to
be relatively uh a straightforward
reduction to do with slight losses uh in
in various places
the interesting reduction here is going
from Pandora's Box where we have these
different costs and boxes and then
taking those costs and replacing them
with boxes being acceptable or
unacceptable uh for different scenarios
okay so how might one do that this is
where uh you know some care needs to be
taken and essentially the idea is that
uh we need to figure out algorithmically
some threshold for determining whether
you know a cost is low enough to be
acceptable or too high and becomes
unacceptable and we we need to pick an
appropriate threshold that covers enough
scenarios but not too many so we can
relate it to the optimal cost
and uh so this kind of a guess and
iterate technique leads to a log log
loss in approximation and so the first
result that I'll State here is this log
M log log M approximation for Pandora's
Box where m is the number of scenarios
okay
so I said before that optimal decision
tree uh is hard to approximate better
than a logarithmic Factor we don't know
the same for Pandora's Box
so maybe there there's one can do much
better here but currently uh my belief
is that
you have to incur something that will
get worse with the the number of
scenarios and
okay like you can't get away with some
dependence on the number of scenarios
so I want to talk to talk next about the
setting where the the number of
scenarios is potentially very very large
or even unbounded so you have like an
unbounded support distribution and then
uh and and we get sample access to this
distribution and now I want to ask well
you know can we say something
interesting if with finite support this
is the best we can do can we say
anything interesting about the case
where m is unbounded
the reduction
as a current exploitation problem
whereas the other one is operation
what is the kind of underlying the
structure yes so here uh you know the
idea is that I want to find a an
acceptable box quickly but now I'm
adding in this uh extra uh you know
feedback about the state of the world
into the problem so now that this is a
more General problem than what I
described on the previous slide so again
the difference from Pandora's Box is
that now we only have acceptable and
unacceptable boxes but we still get some
feedback about the state of War we're in
and the connection to Optimal decision
tree is that in fact this is a simpler
problem than optimal decision tree
because we don't have to identify
exactly which state of the world we're
in as long as we find an acceptable box
right so certainly identification will
help us with this task
okay but uh but here we don't have to
identify the state of the world uh and
so it's a it's a simpler problem and uh
I can tell you offline more about the
reduction but it's basically based off
of that idea
yes so I'll talk about the sample access
settings so
um here we have some underlying
distribution over cost vectors and we
again want to uh find an approximately
optimal probing strategy but all we get
to see about this distribution is a few
draws from it so polynomially many draws
polynomial in the number of boxes
we don't get to see the entire
distribution yeah
if we find a better approximation it
will separate the two problems
okay so let's talk about this uh last
piece the learning from uh limited data
and upshot here is that the problem is
completely hopeless in the setting
okay so here is an example uh to
convince you of that so imagine that our
distribution over costs is such that the
first box this is going to be a cheap to
probe box but it contains complete
information about uh you know the the
location of another box that has uh zero
cost inside it okay so in every state of
the world there's going to be a single
zero cost box we don't know where the
which box that is but the first box is
going to tell us complete information
about it so if only we can decipher the
message in the first box we can uh you
know there's this very simple probing
strategy that will find the location of
the zero cost box and will be done
okay but deciphering this without
actually observing uh the this uh
particular uh instantiation in our
sample is just not possible so unless we
see precisely the same uh state of the
world in our sample uh we cannot hope to
do this
okay and so uh this is it's kind of a
silly example uh in the sense that uh
you know it doesn't really capture uh
anything very interesting about the
problem at hand it's just saying that
you know you you cannot just uh if if
your distribution is completely
arbitrary then you're not asking the
right question
okay that's how I think of it at least
yeah offline uh
no we have offline some poly and end
samples from the entire distribution so
each sample now is going to be an entire
Vector of costs
and I'll give you Paulie and and such
vectors
okay
so
right so we cannot hope to learn the
optimal strategy or anything close to it
from data but now my claim is that we're
this is because we're asking the wrong
question we have the wrong Benchmark
here so I want to talk about benchmarks
here and this is often a conversation we
don't have in the context of algorithm
design what is the Benchmark that we
ought to approximate
and so we saw that uh this Benchmark
that I'll Now call the fully adaptive
Optimum this is a completely arbitrary
decision tree this is uh potentially
hard to approximate uh okay I I told you
that the related optimal decision tree
problem is log M hard to approximate I
don't know the same for Pandora's box
but it's not a stretch to imagine that
it would be so it appears to be hard to
approximate and it's also impossible to
learn from data
what else could we do well we could go
to the other end of the spectrum and ask
for a completely non-adaptive solution
so what is a non-adaptive solution here
so it's not gonna uh it's going to probe
and stop without depending on the data
that it's seen right so what it does is
it it just selects some subset of the
boxes opens them all simultaneously and
then it just selects the best one out of
those okay now the question is which
subset should you open
okay
and the good thing about this
non-adaptive Optimum is that it's easy
to learn from data in the sense that uh
you know in machine learning terms if I
think about the generalization error uh
I just have very few different uh you
know Solutions in this space I only have
two to the N different subsets of boxes
so polynomial and samples is going to
give me enough information to tell what
the best one is if the costs are bounded
so in that sense it's easy to learn from
data samples tell us enough about uh the
the optimization problem but it turns
out that uh this non-adaptive Optimum is
also hard to approximate so in
particular it captures the set cover
problem
and uh so in fact it's hard to
approximate any better than a log in M
uh approximation
okay so now we have these two benchmarks
both are are sort of uh hard in one
sense or another
and one of the things you might do at
this point is to ask uh well can I
approximate the optimum of this so the
the non-adaptive optimum by giving my
algorithm extra power and using full
adaptivity okay and this is uh this
would be uh sorry this would correspond
to like improper learning uh in ml or in
in the context of algorithms it's sort
of like a resource augmentation model
and it's a it's a nice question to ask
and it turns out that uh it's uh
it's ently hard to find a fully optimal
a fully adaptive strategy that will beat
the non-adaptive optimum but you can get
a constant approximation so this is
doable
okay but I won't talk about this I'll
talk about something uh better
which is an intermediate class of uh
solutions that will try to optimize over
and I'll call these partially adaptive
Solutions and these are directly
inspired by weitzman's algorithm this is
why I went through the algorithm at the
beginning of the talk so what these
strategies do is they're going to fix a
particular probing order over boxes
before they've seen anything so the
probing order is going to be
non-adaptive but the stopping rule is
going to be adaptive
foreign
you know gaps between these different
solution Concepts so fully adaptive can
be uh you know much much better than not
non-adaptive of course but so can
partially adaptive be much much better
than non-adaptive so these are very very
different classes of solutions
and so this is what a partially adaptive
strategy looks like in this picture you
have a the same probing order but then
you know the stopping rule can now
depend on data you've seen so far
and the upshot is that this one we will
be able to approximate and learn from
data
and there's a there's this interesting
trade-off between learning and
optimization going on here so you know
as I go from uh left to right I'm uh you
know going to a smaller and smaller uh
solution class and so of course I'm
increasing my representation error right
this this one doesn't quite uh capture
as much of the optimal value as this one
but as I go from right to left I'm
increasing generalization error now I
need more and more samples in order to
be able to learn the optimum
and so this is you know Perfectly
Natural and as we might expect
but uh the computational complexity of
these different classes does not uh you
know correspond to the scale at all this
one is is challenging to approximate
this one's challenging to approximate
this one turns out to be easy to
approximate
so that's that's quite a mystery that's
quite uh interesting uh I think
okay so let me tell you how we can
approximate this and we've already seen
uh the various components so we'll be
able to put them together quickly so now
again we're in the setting where we have
some arbitrary distribution and we have
samples drawn from this distribution
available to us
and the first thing we'll do is to
simplify this stopping rule as we saw we
can do this at small loss okay so we're
going to just worry about coming up with
a good probing order and once we have a
good probing order then we're going to
just use myopic stopping alongside to
get a final solution
another the key observation is that you
know these uh partially adaptive
strategies with this fixed stopping rule
there are only n factorial different you
know n factorial many different
strategies in my set now we're going to
assume that the costs are bounded and
this is enough to say that this uh this
class is is learnable okay polynomial in
and many samples will suffice to be able
to find uh a good solution in the set
okay and that's all that I'll say about
learning but now that we draw these
samples so we saw we draw M samples from
the distribution now we'll just worry
about finding an approximately optimal
solution over these samples
okay and now what we'll do is we'll take
inspiration from uh this long line of
work on bin some set cover and it turns
out that the Min sum set cover problem
without feedback about the state of the
world you know naturally has a partially
adaptive probing order that's optimal
okay and so here uh
this this partial adaptivity the fact
that the probing order is fixed it comes
in very handy in setting up an LP
relaxation for this problem and one can
set this up and uh do a rounding I won't
go into the details but this gives a
constant approximation
again I also want to point out here that
uh so now we're in this world with few
samples but note that we are only
competing or we are only trying to
approximate partially adaptive
strategies not fully adaptive strategies
and so that's why we we are able to get
this constant approximation and we don't
have to suffer a logarithmic and M
approximation
foreign
okay so the upshot is that we get a
constant approximation to The partially
adaptive Optimum this runs in polynomial
time and it uses polynomially many
samples from the underlying distribution
okay so to quickly wrap up I talked
about these two different models of the
distribution the explicitly described
distribution where we can get like a a
log log approximation to the fully
adaptive Optimum and then the sample
access setting where we can get a
constant approximation but only to The
partially adaptive Optimum
and these are just you know these two
different uh uh natural models of
distribution but you can of course ask
you know what if I I knew something else
about my distribution what else can I do
and you know we already know that in
special cases we can do much better
product distribution weitzman's
algorithm uh you know gives the optimal
solution and so I wanna you know in the
the last few seconds just quickly
mention another very nice model uh
distributional model for which we don't
know very much and I think it's a it's a
nice uh setting to explore and try to do
uh something for this is uh you know
this combines sort of different aspects
of these other models so weitzman's
algorithm says that the costs in
different boxes are independent of each
other we could imagine that uh you know
maybe there are a few different state
states of the world and in each state we
are given so we have some product
distribution right so these product
distributions could for example
correspond to uh some noise some
independent noise uh added to the costs
in each box okay but we don't know which
world we are in so we have a mixture
over a few product distributions okay so
now we have a very uh specific kind of
underlying distribution maybe we even
have uh you know an explicit model of
this what can we do in this setting
and uh we don't know very much about
this so it turns out that we can get
a logarithmic approximation so putting
us somewhere close to this in polynomial
time or we can get uh something like a
close to one approximation but in time
that's exponential uh in m
okay but again we don't know any lower
bounds here so uh it's quite possible
that one can do much better
okay
so to wrap up uh I already mentioned a
few different directions for exploration
here uh you know other models of
correlation uh better results you know
closing the gaps some of the gaps I
mentioned other benchmarks this is
another direction that I I think would
be very nice to think about for these
kinds of problems that exhibit large
gaps what are other reasonable
benchmarks to try to uh approximate
I very briefly mentioned combinatorial
selection and it turns out that the
sorts of techniques I described tend to
extend to uh natroid type settings but
don't go beyond and so very nice
question is you know what can we say
about uh the combinatorial settings
where we will be on metroids there's a
very nice question in singla's work
which asks about uh you know shortest
paths in a network you can probe the
lengths of edges can you find
with low cost the shortest path in a
given Network
okay and finally I uh wanna again make
this connection to a budgeted or
constrained settings where we have some
Budget on how much we can spend to gain
information and of course we can Define
the cost of information in many many
different ways make sample complexity
query complexity Etc and one can imagine
Pandora's Box style models with these uh
cost measures that you know internalize
this cost of information and these would
be interesting directions to explore as
well
and thank you very much
[Applause]
so can you comment a little bit on the
other sorts of correlations that uh for
which for which there are results now
yeah I mentioned I have a couple of um
uh references here so it's definitely
not complete but
um there's uh uh so in the in the
context of attribute selection which I
didn't quite Define uh in the talk this
is where
um you know you either select everything
or nothing and so you're you know
gaining some information and trying to
decide should I select everything or not
is it uh you know is the net value uh
greater than some threshold or not and
there there have been models people have
looked at of uh you know uh Paradise
correlation between now the boxes are
called attributes and so uh sort of a
you know small uh correlations between
consecutive attributes and I'll just
point to these couple of references and
I'm happy to tell you more offline uh
but they're you know very specific kinds
of models that arise and
suggestion the fact that you mentioned
in the minimum of some sector what would
that look like because it's just it's
just zeros and one right yeah so it
would be a as if you know the Box had
has two different attributes in it so
one is the the cost acceptable or
unacceptable and the second is uh is
some uh you know hint about the status
word oh so that would be like so it
would be a separate piece of information
yeah thank you
thank you
so the optimal decision tree problem
that you use that's the one where login
hardness is known or there's hope that
it's like a uniform distribution some
special case
for optimal decision three uh the the
reduction that I showed actually reduces
symptom the uniform prior version so you
know it still has the log M plus and but
uh if there's an improvement on the
factor for that uniform prior then this
would also improve uh but the the login
hardness is for the non-uniform prior
version and actually the the as you
probably know the latest word on the
uniform prior uh optimal decision tree I
actually gives an approximation better
than login should be better than login
so it breaks that that hardness between
the two versions
thank you